the Navy officer in charge of the u.s.
7th fleet was relieved of his duties
overnight after the latest deadly
collision involving a destroyer the
removal of Vice Admiral Joseph a coin
follows a string of incidents involving
US warships the USS John S McCain
collided Monday with a commercial tanker
the second deadly accident in three
months for the fleet ten sailors are
thought to have died in this mishap Ben
Tracy is in Beijing and following the
Navy shake up and good morning good
morning it has been an absolutely
horrible summer for the u.s. seventh
Fleet which is based in Japan they have
likely lost 17 of their sailors two of
their warships are extensively damaged
and now the commander of the entire
fleet has lost his job the damage was
significant this was not a small
collision just two months ago Vice
Admiral Joseph altcoin promised a
sweeping investigation following the USS
fitzgerald's deadly collision with a
merchant ship off the coast of Japan but
after the USS John S McCain crashed
earlier this week the Navy decided to
remove all coin from his post as head of
the seventh Fleet the mccain's collision
was the latest of four incidents
involving his ships in just the past
eight months
Vice Admiral Aucoin has led the seventh
Fleet since September 2015 and was set
to retire next month the divers were
able locate some remains in those sealed
compartments in a press conference
yesterday Pacific Fleet Commander
Admiral Scott Swift said the Navy is
looking at all possible causes for the
collision between the McCain in an oil
tanker Monday near Singapore including a
cyberattack on the ship's controls he
promised to get to the root cause of
these incidents in the Pacific when
tragedy like this is one too many
and while each of these four events is
unique they cannot be viewed in
isolation the Navy has not released the
names of the McCain's missing sailors
but at least three of them have been
identified by family members the
families of Logan Palmer and Kenneth
Smith think those expressing concern for
their missing sons and Meagan Partlow
said of her missing fiance Jacob Drake I
am slowly losing hope and it hurts to
know I might never
to walk down the aisle to see the love
of my life the Navy is now expanding the
search area in the hopes of finding some
of these 10 missing sailors still alive
meanwhile the Pacific Fleet is going to
conduct what they're calling a
deliberate reset of all of their ships
basically here they're gonna bring in
experts who will assess and train all of
the crews that's a story thank you very
much Ben Tracy reporting from Beijing